eww
[musique]
Pouah
eww
[musique]
5w
euh 5
eww
eww ce
euh d'être aussi
[musique]
eww
courtiser 5
[musique]
Pouah
5w
pouah pouah
[musique]
Dès que j'ai entendu la nouvelle, j'ai su que j'en avais besoin.
Euh, maintenant je suis en train de revoir la partie du plan
Parce que l'exigence est juste de mettre du GNL, la température ne sera jamais
Vous pouvez régler le son pour qu'il ne monte ni ne descende.
Avec cette grande quantité de réfrigérant très faible, que faire dans cette grande quantité comme cette fois
Le stockage en vrac nécessite des températures stables
[musique]
Vous entendrez tous les préparatifs pour accueillir le peuple
Envoyez tous les Bonghamun existants, y compris le maquereau, et saluez le 110e.
Prêt à partir
[musique]
eww